loved him in Breaking Bad currently and
better call Saul for what she's been
nominated for an Emmy Maze Runner fans
love this guy as well and I could go on
and on about your filmography but I want
to talk about also jet on Cinemax a
title character played by carla Gugino
however she gets mixed up with the man
to my right the man who plays Charlie at
Baudelaire in this great show on Cinemax
Friday nights at 10:00 good to see you
Giancarlo Esposito great to see you rich
great to be back to see you sir so let's
let's just real briefly talk about our
team which is not just epics which will
to get to you in a second
but the New York Yankees who again you
grew up on this team correct I sure did
right around the corner correct right
around the corner and and it just seems
to me that this team is just it's been
red-hot lately so red-hot you know all
these young guys are on the team all of
our starters had just went down with
injuries here there and everywhere
including your namesake John Carlos hurt
me that hurt me hurt me hurt me almost
as much as him absolutely absolutely
he's out for a while isn't it how many
at-bats has he had this year like 10
it's been I don't know when he's coming
back quite a shame but the young bucks
have stepped up and really pulled this
team out right they've come together and
in a really rejuvenated fashion and it
had some pretty long games that they've
had the 5-hour one I you know it was so
crazy this week how many well how many
has 38 plate appearances that's crazy
that's crazy and there is there they've
got let me get this accurate they have
an 11 game lead on the Red Sox going
into a four-game series doing quite
phenomenal in Fenway Park and that to me
like you know and and Mariano Rivera go
went into the Hall of Fame is the first
unanimously selected play unbelievable I
mean figure that history had been made
right but that's a hard one to get into
a Hall of Fame isn't it yeah you try you
try you try again I know but he's a
classy guy with an incredible record
that may not be surpassed right 652
saves now you got I have to ask you
something yes sir did he start as a
starter he did he did so my childhood
memory of that
nice is correct yes yes yes yes started
in 95 and as a starter and you know when
he got unanimously selected to the Hall
of Fame on his first shot last earlier
this year we had Joe Torre on the show
because you know we try to go straight
up the flow chart best we can he went
right to the dog went right to the top
and he started talking about how early
in 96 when he first got the job that
they didn't know what they had in
Mariano and they also were nervous about
their new rookie shortstop named Derek
Jeter being able to handle the gig every
single day as a rookie so they almost
traded Rivera to Seattle for a shortstop
Felix for mean and I I almost just broke
into a cold sweat over that being
anywhere near remotely possible oh my
goodness
yeah and we had you imagine and we had
David Cohen on the other day talking
about Rivera and he said that Rivera's a
difference between him having one World
Series ring in for Wow you know what
great credit that I mean he's he's just
the all-time best they did the right
thing with him yes what if they kept him
as a starter would he have gotten
injured would he have would he have made
it the history he's made I don't think
so I don't think so either I don't think
so either I mean he put people to sleep
and the Sandman just did it all the way
right but what I loved about him was he
always carried himself with grace and
aplomb and he's humble and I love humble
people yep and in English is a second
language and here his speech was
remarkable remarkable I know truely's
great who was you who was your Yankee
growing up Oh
Thurman Munson I was a catcher when I
played Little League is that right and I
loved Thurman Munson I just love the way
he played I loved that he had he his
physicality yes he was just a tough egg
I really dug him yeah I know I remember
where I was when when I learned about
his passing and I think about him all
the time because we're going to Canton
Ohio that's the airport where he passed
away that's where the Hall of Fame Beit
Football Hall of Fame is Wow I know so
it's I think of him every single time I
land in Canton Airport I was so broken
up about I was too great player Regent
great players Giancarlo Esposito here on
the Rich Eisen show before we get to jet
I'm gonna do my usual geek out with me
here
better call Saul are you shooting it
right now we are right now right now
okay right now and obviously you'd have
to you'd have to kill me before you gave
me anything any information I just I
just wet myself that actually just
happened we've got a great show and Saul
we really do we're in our fifth season
the writing keeps getting better and
better and better
yes Bob Odenkirk who congratulations to
Bob and Jonathan as well who are also
nominated me for this yet fourth season
the fifth season is just coming closer
and closer to Breaking Bad and it gets a
little more frightening with every
episode we shoot these guys are
brilliant I have to say well it is
brilliant too because the only thing I
can I can equate it to is seeing let's
just say the movie miracle right I know
how it's going to work out for all the
characters in the movie miracle I know
that they are going to beat the Russians
and win the miracle on ice
Gold Medal eventually but I'm on the
edge of my seat absolutely I know what's
going to happen to your character and
every other character but I'm on the
edge of my seat and I want to know what
this journey is all about and how they
wound up being the characters that we
all you know fell in love with or
downright frightened of in Breaking Bad
absolutely I'm going backwards as you
know what's happened to me already I'm
going backwards and playing a little bit
younger a little more naive little more
vulnerable maybe not so hot-headed may
be more ruthless maybe a little bit less
ruthless but certainly when you have
writers who write a show that's about
interaction about human interaction yes
then you get you get some real emotion
and some real connection going on we
have a wonderful cast and it's great to
be there with them in this new
incarnation never imagined I would be
back after playing Gustavo Fring in
isn't that amazing
isn't that amazing do you do you know do
they know how this all lines up I mean
obviously we know we know eventually
what Breaking Bad is about but the
connective tissue how the eventual I
think somewhere in their office on all
those 3x5 cards they have on the wall
right and the variables switch around
and say we could do it this way this way
or this way I think
have a clear indication of exactly how
it's all going to end before we get to
break you do believe that I do okay I do
and you're it's just I can't wait when
does this the one good thing for me yes
is uh I'm not gonna die
[Laughter]
you and your fellow actors and actresses
that know that you don't have to keep
turning the pages to find that out
precisely because you know eventually
where well I don't want to I keep saying
you know like sport like it's a spoiler
alert but we have a an artist rendering
of your unfortunate demise that's behind
our set every single day I see you every
day I love it essentially I love it you
mean your consciousness to face every
single day all right let's talk about
jet on Cinemax right now 10:00 p.m.
Eastern every single Friday and the the
finales coming up in august you play
another well-adjusted individual very
well in charge of a crime a family quit
your crime boss what what is there
something similar that you found I mean
what what attracts you to a role like
like this one I really just wanted to
play with carla Gugino
and Sebastien Gutierrez the director of
the piece they pitched me in a way that
was very very different because the so
many creative elements go into making a
television show and this one has the
noir element of it I wanted to play this
guy as slightly over-the-hill crime boss
everyone sees that he does not he still
thinks he's in control and you mentioned
something family crime family there's
the twist in this particular show
Charlie has a son who is a wild card
and being so you can never trust the guy
and so we in this family Charlie
underestimates the power of his son and
his son's intentions and I think
intention is everything and when you
start to when you live your life you
have good intentions good things come
back Charlie has intentions to make
money and to go out of this clime family
eventually but he never gets there never
gets there never gets there and and
season one is wrapping up
coming up in the early parts of August
Friday August night so and you can get
in while the getting's good watching it
every single week or just check things
out on demand 10:00 p.m. Eastern Friday
nights on Cinemax dear white people on
Netflix Friday August the second you are
the narrator of this can you tell people
what this is all about
oh this show is an interesting show
Justin Simien who wrote the show wrote
about an experience of black a black
University and which is a place where we
get to investigate black and white
relationships and I started as a
narrator and they love what I did and
they asked me to come back and be on
camera but it's a world that we don't
see very much of okay and it is done in
a very comedic way it's a funny show
interesting and you should watch Volume
three coming out on Netflix again August
the second and Godfather of Harlem this
looks awesome
oh well I mean you're playing Adam
Clayton Powell jr. and this is on FX
premiering on September 29th the cast
includes Forest Whitaker Vincent
D'Onofrio Paul Sorvino just to name a
few and you sir
I love playing historical characters I
dove in deep for this one to learn more
about Adam Clayton Powell and all of the
great things he did in his record as a
congressman as a preacher Minister an
Abyssinian Baptist Church as a womanizer
a drinker rabble rouser yes but someone
who really cared about the people eight
hundred and fifty two bills he passed in
Congress and wrote himself including
National Endowment of the Arts minimum
wage Act but when I get into a character
that that I feel like I have to play a
character whose historical I channel and
so I listen to his speeches this show is
truly terrific written by Chris Brancato
and Paul Eckstein and Forest Whitaker is
amazing in playing bumpy Johnson who is
another historical character who tried
to wrestle away the prostitution and the
drug trade from the mob in Harlem in the
60s so I'll ask you this question since
again you you've you're playing so many
different types of
characters what do you like to do the
most what character yeah I gotta tell
you I love the bad guy
I love the bad guy this is now an ax
plate and Powell is a good guy he's fun
right and that's gonna change the
audience's of view of Who I am you sure
because I have a ball playing this
character he's intelligent he's smart
he's fun and he gets the gal that works
and so out of all because again in
better call Saul you have the gift not
only being great at what you do but then
to play a character at a different point
in the character's life after you
thought maybe you never play the
character again is there another
character from your filmography that
you'd love to take that crack at oh my
goodness I can't think of one well yes
there is excuse me revolution
you know revolution I wasn't finished
with that show I really felt like Eric
Kripke who created that show and JJ
Abrams were really fabulous had fabulous
vision and Tom Neville was a guy who was
a survivor and I had a lot more to give
so there is there is that character
someone said to me the other day look
you know I feel honored because this
nomination has been really wonderful for
the Emmy I feel like I've already won
because I've been nominated for a
character I played in two different
shows I didn't even realize it right you
know I did Breaking Bad nominated for
that and now nominated for a better call
Saul so I feel honored and I feel like
I've already won okay well you deserve
it man you're so good at it
you are just so good at at what you do
and I always appreciate that you stop by
here whenever you're promoting what you
know I love coming here I'll tell you
why okay because I sit in that green
room and I watch you okay
and I learn and I watch you and I watch
you and I learned so much about sports
because I travel so much I work so much
okay I miss things so I get filled in
okay what's happening right now I love
it
bye Rich Eisen I appreciate that I mean
by the way I'm available at any time if
you want you know just do you I direct I
did you definitely know all right so now
I'm you want me to act
are you offering a role right now I want
you to act I think it'd be a new
breakthrough for you well should I
should I open
my latest residual check yes just show
him that you got the job
yeah yes that's right give us something
can you stick around for worse one quick
more segment of course okay you get okay
I've just been told you can't he's got
to go people get a poem okay okay no as
people are saying it's okay alright
let's take a break real quick just my
television only segment I'm gonna oppa
is I open my residual checks from
sag-aftra live on the show he's offering
me a role which it sounds like you are I
will show you my if you will filmography
that's proof is that proof is that
little proof for you guys I mean that's
pretty he's been in stuff that's that
stuff so let me just get this right
before we throw it a break when we come
back we're gonna finish up this show
Giancarlo Esposito will be gone by then
but we'll have a television only segment
with you sir we'll open up my residual
checks the first season of Jett on
Cinemax continues on Friday at 10:00
p.m. Eastern Time check out volume 3 of
dear white people on Netflix Friday
August the 2nd and then on epics
Godfather of Harlem premiering September
29th I cannot wait to see that and of
course you back on the air with whatever
you're cooking up right now and I use
that phrase in particular for the next
episode and season it better call Saul
absolutely okay that said don't go
anywhere back with Giancarlo Esposito on
the television side in a second I've
opened my residual checks live on TV
before but never with a man who has a
hundred and seventy eight film credits
to his own Giancarlo Esposito are you
ready to already I'm like nervous and
excited to open up my residual checks
right next to you right here already
okay roll it roll it please we even have
a little sting here go for it
[Music]
that's me and his money my left or right
hand which one should I open I want you
left okay here we go
here we go now you say you have a
residual what's what's the residual
change trading places years ago classic
movie yes
big big film I got a residual check for
one you know you played a very integral
scene with Eddie Murphy from that film
it's very important give the guy a penny
here we go here we go oh the residual
check this is from the movie like Mike
alright yeah yes remember like my shirt
that was you I would as a sports center
anchor and like Mike here we go love it
there's a residual check ladies and
gentlemen it is for five dollars and 36
cents you see right here I love that you
got a one cent one cent you saved it you
gotta save it
oh of course I did a residual check
Ashley places that was one single penny
all right this one is let's see if this
is another Wayback Machine Disney's the
kibbeh kill which is the first movie
myself
wait what movie did you place to Scott
uh that was uh Disney's a kid yes Stuart
Scott and I were in it together as
Sports Center anchors and we credit each
other as the other so I'm creditors the
Stewart's Scotty's credit is good job I
can't believe this this is from so long
ago $20
[Applause]
check out Jen on Cinemax Fridays at
10:00 Eastern for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV for free on BR live or download
the Rich Eisen show app